but we're going to begin with a
challenge that is very quickly becoming
a crisis for many parents of young
children you all keep hearing these
stories we all do about moms and dads
finding empty shelves when they go
looking for new supplies a formula for
their little babies this is a national
shortage and it we're sorry to say is
getting worse formula is now 43 out of
stock nationwide that's up from 31 last
month nancy cordes will have more on the
biden administration's response in just
a moment but first we're going to go to
adriana diaz for more on this story
adriana good morning to you
good morning well abbott the nation's
largest supplier of baby formula
headquartered outside chicago says its
michigan plant could restart within two
weeks but it could be up to two months
for that new product to land on shelves
you might remember abbott had to shut
its factory down after a recall and
parents have become consumed by the hunt
for formula
new mom jaylene oriana is so desperate
for baby formula she's willing to drive
14 hours to pick up formulas she had her
aunt by in mexico i'd rather be
safe like have cans stocked up then
sorry to my daughter that not knowing
when she's going to eat this week the 19
year old from houston drove three hours
to get formula from a dad who didn't
need it in austin they connect it on a
social media site like this one where
parents post if they need formula or
have extra are you worried that you're
not going to be able to find formula for
your baby one of these days i am
i'm willing to drive
whatever i have to drive as the shortage
grows families are scrambling but
pediatricians like dr joshua wexler are
warning parents not to water down
formula or try homemade recipes you
can't ensure the micronutrient calorie
density is all correct
that you're using the appropriate water
source potentially there might be a lot
of issues those who find formula face a
tough choice like michigan mom destiny
featherstone whose youngest is four
months old yesterday there was like just
enough for her mom's supply and i wanted
to get it all but i was like i want to
take from the other babies virginia mom
erica lopez says she never knows if
she'll find formula on the shelves when
my daughter doesn't drink the whole
bottle i'm like oh my gosh she just
wasted like two three ounces i'm like
that was like a scoop that we could have
saved back in texas orianna says she
buys extra formula when she sees it but
not for the reason you might think she
says she's sending the extra cans to
other families to help them
i bought it
to help i mean i know how it feels
it's hard
oh adriana this is heartbreaking for a
lot of parents listen you've got a new
baby in the house a favorite daughter
you're covering the story but are you
part of the story too
well gail you know it has been stressful
to find formula for my eight-month-old
isabella but you know one time actually
at a store i was able to find the last
two boxes of formula and i and i grabbed
them but then honestly i heard tony
decouple's voice in my head telling me
not to hoard because you guys have been
talking about it on the show so i ended
up leaving a box luckily we recently
signed up for formula subscription
service just days before they stopped
taking new members so we're really
fortunate
well i'm sorry my voice is in your head
but i do think another parent is very
happy you did that adriana
this is what happens when tony decouple
gets in your head adriana thank you very
much